so we've made some good progress in our
derivation of parts of the lawrence
transformation we've been able to
express x prime in terms of our lorentz
factor and x and v and t and we've been
able to switch things around and
represent x in terms of the lorenz
factor and x prime and v and t prime and
we're able to solve for the lorentz
factor now the final missing piece in
order for us to have the full
transformation is to express t prime in
terms of x and t so how can we do that
well the way i'm going to tackle it is
i'm just going to take this equation
right over here let me underline it i'm
just going to take that equation right
over there and solve for t prime and the
parts that have an x prime in it i'm
going to substitute with this so let's
do that so let's solve this for t prime
so the first thing that i want to do is
i want to divide both sides of this
equation by the lorentz factor or by
gamma so if i do that i'm going to get
and i'm going to move it over to the
left so i have more space it's going to
be x
over
gamma
x over gamma is equal to is equal to x
prime
x prime
plus
v
plus v
times t prime
t
prime let me do that same blue color
and everything i'm going to do here is
pretty straightforward algebra but it's
going to get a little hairy so that's
why i want to take some some caution
with the colors and progress slowly now
since i want to solve for t prime let me
subtract x prime from both sides so the
left hand side is going to be x
over
gamma
x over that looks like a v too much x
over gamma minus x prime
minus
x prime
is equal to
v times t prime
v times
t prime and now to solve for t prime
let's just divide both sides by v
and so we are going to get
x
let me do that white color
we're going to get x over well now it's
going to be gamma v
so gamma
v
v is in that orange color gamma v
minus
x prime
over v
is going to be equal to
is equal to
t prime
so now we'll do what i said before we
we've we've solved for t prime in terms
of now gamma v x and x prime but now we
can take that x prime and replace it
with gamma and all of this business
right over here so let's do that so if
we
if we take
this and substitute it in for x prime
and actually let me swap sides too we
are going to get t prime
is equal to
x
x over
gamma
the gamma in that red color
over gamma
times
v
minus
this stuff so we're going to have
gamma
times
it's a little bit tedious but we'll
power through it
x
minus v t
x minus v
t and at any point you get inspired i
encourage you to run with it so that's
what that's we just replaced x prime
with this stuff over here and then we're
gonna have all of that over v
so all of that
over
v
and now what we can do let's see
well we could let's let's factor out
let's factor out a
gamma out of everything
so we will get
t prime
is equal to
gamma
times
and we're going to have is going to get
pretty hairy now gamma times
x
over gamma squared
x over gamma squared you factor out a
gamma here or another way to think about
gamma times x over gamma square is going
to be x over gamma we still have that v
over there
v
and then minus
minus
and actually let me just distribute the
minus sign the negative sign so minus x
over v
minus
x
over v
x over
v looking forward to this getting a
little bit simpler and then a negative
times a negative is a positive so it's
going to be plus vt divided by v well
that's just going to be plus t
so plus t so simplify it a little bit
plus
t
so we're making some progress here
and so that is going to be equal to
actually let me just since i so i don't
have to keep rewriting everything let me
just focus on this part right over here
try to simplify it and actually even
better let me just focus let me just
focus on that part right over there
so that part we can factor out an x
so if we factor out an x it is going to
be equal to
it is going to be equal to x
times
one over gamma squared v
so let me write that down
one
over
gamma squared v
look at the colors right
gamma squared
v
gamma squared v
and then
minus 1 over v
so
we have the minus
1 over v
over
v
now if we want to subtract these two
things let me put the close parenthesis
if we want to subtract these two things
it's nice to have a common denominator
so let's multiply the numerator and
denominator here by gamma squared
so
this is gamma squared
gamma
squared and so
now i'm going to focus on
i'm going to focus on this part right
over here and hopefully this will
simplify nicely this is the same thing
as 1
minus gamma squared
gamma squared
over
gamma squared v
gamma i picked a different color
over
gam i'm having trouble switching colors
gamma squared
gamma squared v
now what does this simplify to well it
seems like it'll be useful to have a
different way of writing well let's
think about what gamma squared is gamma
is this business right over here which
we could if we were to square it
gamma squared
gamma looks like a v again
gamma squared is going to be equal to
1 over 1 minus v squared over c squared
i just squared the numerator 1 squared
is 1. take the square of the square root
you're just going to get that and if i
want to simplify a little bit
i can multiply the numerator and the
denominator by
i can multiply the numerator and
denominator by c squared and so then
that's going to be equal to
c squared over you multiply the
denominator by c squared you're going to
get c squared
minus
v squared
so how does that help us well this
business
this business one we can write as
one we can write as c squared minus v
squared over c squared minus v squared
so let's do that c squared
minus v squared over c squared minus v
squared i just did that so it has the
same denominator as gamma squared and
then we're going to subtract gamma
squared so we're going to subtract
we're going to
subtract
c squared
over
c squared minus v squared and it looks
like this is going to simplify nicely
because well let me just do one step at
a time and we're going to have all of
that
all of that over
gamma squared is once again
is once again
c squared
over c squared minus v squared and we're
going to multiply that times v
times
do the v in that same color all of that
v
and see up here in the numerator i have
c squared minus v squared
minus c squared so
so what's going to happen is
this and we have the same denominator so
this and that are going to cancel and so
this whole expression is going to
simplify to
is going to simplify to negative v and
let me do that same v color
negative
v squared
over
c squared minus v squared
and we're dividing by this and that's
the same thing as multiplying by the
reciprocal so let's multiply by this
reciprocal so times c squared minus v
squared c squared minus v squared
over
c squared times v and we are now in the
home stretch
c squared times v and we could do some
simplification now that's going to
cancel with that and then
v squared divided by v you're just going
to be left with a v right over there so
all of this crazy business has
simplified to
a negative v and i'll just write it in
that orange color it is all simplified
to negative v
over
c squared so all of
all of this has simplified to negative v
over
c squared and so we're in the home
stretch this expression t prime
is going to be equal to
gamma
it's going to be equal to gamma times
let's write this t first
so t
and then this expression
has simplified to negative v over c
squared times x so we can write this as
minus
minus v
over c squared
times x
times
x and we're done we have just completed
our lawrence transformation we started
with this that we've been able to show
in the last few videos and we did a
little bit of harry carefully did a
little bit of hairy algebra to get this
result t prime is equal to gamma times t
minus v over c squared times x